up like a fine
dining
experience
for everybody that's coming tonight so
Crimson got a buttering sugar first
Camilla Alves and Matthew McConaughey's
kids show off their culinary skills for
a good cause what better Legacy could we
leave
our children on Wednesday the proud mama
shared this clip with her mom and two of
her three children fourteen-year-old son
Levi and 13 year old daughter Vida
teaming up in the kitchen during Paris
Fashion Week to create a fine dining
experience for the homeless okay
in the caption Camilla explained that
they did everything cooking serving and
cleaning all to create a first class
dinner experience for people in need and
homeless in Paris bringing their dignity
to Front Line it's a great experience I
think you get more than what you're
giving the mom of three says they
whipped up some yummy banana bread and
she encourages her fans to volunteer too
a practice the McConaughey's also do
when they're home I grew up doing it
like since I'm a little girl as long as
I can't remember what it was with the
homeless whether it was with the elders
and showing our kids and having them
being involved on what we're doing it
doesn't take much to help somebody else
right we are fortunate to have a very
affluent life I'm not I have having to
worry if I can pay the rent next week
I'm thankful for that there's a lot of
people that do it's very grounding for
us I think it's good it's hopefully
going to be grounding for our children
too to appreciate every little thing
Camilla Levi and Vita's Day of Service
comes just days after they made a rare
public appearance at the Stella
McCartney show in the city of light the
trio stepped out in coordinating outfits
Levi looking a whole lot like his A-list
dad I love it meanwhile Vita was the
spitting image of her mom and Camilla
she looked Trey Chic they're a
fashionable they're in the trend not in
attendance Matthew and their youngest
kid 10 year old Livingston in the
youngest one who you have to ease young
Livingston out of bed and waking Greek
the day without coming out of Rage
Matthew and Livingston appeared to be
having their own adventure
how you doing
earlier this month the Oscar winner
shared this snap to Instagram with a
little pun in the caption sign up to
sundown having children as you're
reminded that's really good for an adult
my job is that you reminded to see
everything for the first time raising
them and they're seeing things for the
first time so that freshness in that
innocence is very good so whether
they're giving back going to fancy
fashion shows or taking in some epic
nature the McConaughey's are living
their best lives
[Music]
thank you